hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slender craft all you
love is a Minecraft and/or slender have
now a new favorite game that you can
play fun for the whole family it's where
you die from Slenderman and he's gonna
kill you okay so this is pretty much
exactly as it sounds its Slenderman in
the Minecraft world you must craft if
you want to survive I did not know that
was gonna be on the way ooh this looks
very familiar god it's weird I haven't I
haven't actually played you know many
good slender games in a while but I did
found a Flintstone yabba dabba doo
achieving God okay good I thought I was
just gonna be finding pages why do I
need to go yabba dabba doing oh oh
that's a portal I came in I don't know
if I included this cinematic that was at
the beginning of this game but basically
Steve from minecraft went into another
portal and got thrust into the world of
Slender now this actually isn't played
in Minecraft if you couldn't tell I mean
it may look it because the textures have
been re skinned but this is actually
made in like unity or something I
believe but I Wow oh sorry my head
itches my face itches I'm really weird
ah
bringing back some memories gotta
remember when I played like the first
original give me that you'll press
harder crap metal you had the true metal
okay what did that do for me these are
the oil tankers from like the beginning
of the game which meant that the like
the house that was around here has got
to be somewhere well I don't remember
there being a giant wall in the
beginning of the game I mean it has been
so long since I've played the original
Slender god I remember how much that
scared me
like for real like you may think that
slender is its typical
John scary ax the back then it was just
like with five nights at Freddy's you
had no idea what was going on you had no
idea what's coming for you you had no
idea what was to expect this is not the
big red dildo that I remember and
there's so many inside jokes are waiting
for you have you not checked him out
check him out oh man
Thunder like was one of the big first
games that I played that actually went
somewhere oh you fool
hey call me oh whoa was that mean here
in Rio de entrada me whatever I'm trying
to say
I don't think so mismo hey that is him
huh
was that him that is him okay all right
all right okay all right gimme gimme
gimme gimme
I don't know why I'm run dos run second
note of eight gray he so says my
achievement counter up there he's only
on my tail he's only gonna kill me dead
okay
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme all right it's coming
around the corner oh god he's here I
think he's here I think he's here oh I
think he was there all God woods okay
we're starting to get into think of it
both literally and figuratively I don't
know what I'm trying to say anymore I
don't recognize any of these landmarks
they all look very different to me he's
right behind me isn't he god damn it he
is see him I see him poking through the
trees there I can't sprint much more but
I don't like it I'm first fast a third
of eight almost the half thanks you're
very useful
driving yeah
is very useful these notes are yes see
you must craft if you want to survive I
know you said that but that doesn't mean
it's gonna help me at all because I
don't know what these crap tables are
actually gonna do to me for me to me I
don't know I don't know anymore
trying to keep an eye out for pages but
I know time to deviate from the path
because he is right on my bum bum he's
gonna be right up my bum bum in no time
imagine there's got to be a page in here
but I was it overlooking it very quickly
because it was just sprinting in and out
ah I knew it minecraft rules Wow
does it rule as much as it once did that
is the eternal burning question
I mean arguably it's more popular than
it ever was because so many people play
it but I mean there was something about
the original days of Minecraft and this
is something I talked about a lot on
live streams that I talked to my drunk
minecraft series he's right by amazing
okay not quite yet but there was
something to the old charm of
minecraft that I really enjoyed where
why oh god he's always right behind me
I'm on Ross Brent juice but anyway it
was something about the mixture of the
music and like how the game was played
oh oh I made alright
I made a flashlight I don't know how
that's gonna help me but it's a little
bit brighter around here what am I gonna
do I can't get away from him I can't
sprint anymore
ah world bad anyway uh in the beginning
of the Minecraft it was really cool
because I love just being in the world
and existing there and just like the the
feeling of loneliness and isolation was
a big part of Minecraft for me I mean
multiplayer removed a lot of that and
that's not a bad thing multiplayer was
necessary for Minecraft to be as popular
as it is today but for me like the
minecraft experience was just wandering
around in the world alone like doing
nothing oh look I'll try not to but I
keep turning around run if you can but I
enjoyed just being in the Minecraft
world listening to the music and
crafting in an area of almost total
isolation but the magic of it was that
you may be alone but the world is yours
to create like you literally do anything
and everything in this world do you have
no restrictions but at the same time
like the beauty of it was that no one
else is there to appreciate it it's all
things that you do for yourself and not
necessarily for the benefit of anyone
else time again multi Blair came along
and everybody was able to share their
incredible inventions and then a whole
bunch of youtubers who spawned up by it
and I enjoyed the game thoroughly
playing with my friends being blasted
drunk and playing all the bods at the
same time it's just that charm that ding
dong damn charm I got six notes by the
way I'm almost done I can just get away
from this guy because he seems to be
very persistent ok what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna walk around the outskirts
of the walls here because I don't know
where else it wants me to go ok I don't
know if I got one in all of these thick
woods so I imagine there might be one on
the inside of these trees in here
anybody
and her body whoa don't you want
somebody to love don't you need sign
knew it I knew it I knew there had to be
a goddamn thing in there he's gonna get
me isn't all hail metal well I mean
metal is very useful there's various
different types of metal I only need one
North Oh God that's bad
they just turned horrible is he gonna
give me oh that's not bad how am I
supposed to be able to get what I don't
know where he is
oh it suddenly turned awful I was just
having an exposition on minecraft I like
these both in times of gaming holy crap
he's okay I need to like I know it's
gotta be like on the inside area because
I've done the outskirts god stop that
I'm guessing that doesn't actually mean
anything unless just you doing your
thing but still tricking me out don't do
it I didn't want to be freaked out right
now
whoa whoa I can't get me now I'm gonna
come this horse Lenny dick oh oh how did
I miss that I've been through this thing
like 10 times he's stolen me back to the
portal if you have a flashlight I do
don't look behind escape okay
how do I know where the portal is I
don't remember what the portal oh I know
where the portal is now I guess uh I got
the flashlight am I gonna win Wow into
the winner's circle save his victorious
aah
oh that ain't good Ron Steve Ron oh wow
so getting a quick three arita-san isn't
it game over
don't tell me game over tell me the end
I won that anyway so that was
slender craft I was actually pretty
enjoyable I wasn't running around for a
little bit that but that may because I
missed a note that was in front of my
face totally could have been I did not
see that thing for a while but either
way it was a great game I loved it I
don't know if there's any other secrets
that could be found but you can play
this game for yourself through the link
in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
all for your constant support check out
the other slender games I've done and
also check out drunk minecraft it's one
of my favorites long-running series we
haven't been able to record in a while
but I plan to strike it up again because
it's a lot of fun to get drunk and play
with friends so thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye I was told that you were
gonna be here your face freakin simply
knows
okay
what wispy middle